from the miami new times
coincidence alexandria ocasio-cortez
caught covid after partying in miami i
mean that's the gist of the story we saw
uh the news over the past couple of
weeks that aoc was seen hugging people
getting kissed by people
partying at a drag club and this is
coming from a person who has routinely
ragged actually you know what let me
just pull the tweet we got this tweet
from aoc herself where she said 93.2
percent of texans aren't fully
vaccinated mind you this is march 2nd
the state just endured one disaster
worsened by selfishness and denial of
basic science and now conditions are
being set for another repealing the mask
mandate now endangers so many people
especially essential workers and the
vulnerable so perhaps her concern of the
mass mandate was only because of limited
vaccinations
and now she's changed her opinion sure
that's fine but she's also criticized
ron desantis of florida which i would
just say is wrong because she's choosing
to go party in his state while
criticizing him for the policies that
allows her to go party in a state and
now she has coveted so poetic justice or
or what hypocrisy well when you when you
try to silence speech when you weaponize
compliance and you disregard your own
decrees that you complain about other
people not following you're not on the
side of good it's also important to note
here that with this particular tweet on
march of 21 that she of course is
asserting that people will get hurt that
there will be some devastating
consequences because of texas moving
away from mandates moving away from top
down centralization of power of force
against the people who are living there
and the numbers don't lie when you look
at what happened in texas after this and
you compare it to what happened in new
york there's a story there that of
course is being hidden away from the
general public that's how i see it and
uh
you know i don't wish anyone would be
sick i don't think we should be
celebrating anyone be sick uh but you
know there this is the story that's
happening right now that is deserved to
at least be mentioned in my opinion i
think if i if i zoom out for my ego i
want her to be healthy i want it to be
easy like a low symptom or no symptom
illness and be done with it and realize
okay it's not that as bad as i thought
it was going to be kind of thing that's
what i want for the general system i
don't want to play hate and love with
this girl whatever but
it's the policy man
it's it's
if you're if you're in new york if
you're a congress person if you're a
governor and you're defending or
refusing to speak up in the face of
vaccine madness and mass mandates and
then you decide for my vacation i'm
going to go to the one i'm going i'm
going to go to one of the places where
they don't have these policies so i can
go party
i mean that is
that is everything wrong with politics
in my opinion i see i see conservatives
or republicans being like i don't like
mass mandates i won't wear one and then
they don't i'm like well that's what
they said i get it aoc who's like you
know the governor here can give ronda
santa some pointers and mass mandates
are important and then but i'm gonna go
party where the governor does the
opposite that it's the hypocrisy i can't
stand the single most
valuable thing right now is the thing
that's most singularly missing and
that's consistency
we're desperate for people i don't even
think it matters so much what they say
if it lines up with what they do in a
fairly consistent way that person right
now is going to be both respected and
probably in demand regardless of what
side of the aisle you sit on you know i
live in northern california and i wrote
pretty
pointedly
when the whole french laundry thing
happened with gavin newsom
you know i just said look this is not a
small thing you know you remember he was
oh yeah he's out there and he's without
a mask shortly after telling everybody
they had to wear a mask and didn't help
that it was a super fancy schmancy
restaurant and he was with all his
buddies it was just a bad look
but
i just remember saying listen when it
comes to politics speaking only for
myself
i'll forgive stupidity i'll forgive
people being wrong and i'll forgive
people changing their minds
but it's really hard to forgive a
hypocrite yeah mike there was medical
professionals from the government of
california coming forward and saying
along with bureaucrats every time you
have a bite you need to put on your mask
afterwards as they were telling people
not to gather in large groups they were
shutting down restaurants all over
california as he's going to have a
dinner at one of the fanciest
restaurants in the world sure with a
huge crowd and then thankfully because
of citizen journalism because of people
caring about the story this story was
able to get out there to the general
public and show the hypocrisy show just
how hypocritical a lot of these people
are that will ruin your life while
living their best life which is crazy i
wonder if it's you know for for people
who
align themselves with like the
democratic establishment or who are
democratic uh activists they overlook
the new some stuff or the or the whitmer
the pelosi or the maxine waters or you
know the list goes on i wonder if they
overlook that because their attitude is
the messaging is more important it
doesn't matter if a handful of people
are flouting the rules and ignoring it
so long as they're telling everyone to
follow the rules to keep us safe and
then i wonder if you know for
post-liberal libertarian conservative
whatever their attitude is are you being
honest are you an honest politician
which is rare to be honest it depends
how scared you are right if the if the
populace is freaked out to an eight or a
nine
they'll
absorb a level of hypocrisy that they
won't when they're at a five or a six or
a four or a five now we're becoming i've
just noticed it in the last couple of
weeks we're becoming less scared i just
had it got through it my folks both have
it they've come through it
it's not now just a question of how many
people do you know who have had it it's
we're starting to see and you can chalk
it up to omicron or therapeutics or the
uh
therapeutic nature of the vaccines
whatever it is people seem to be having
a much easier ride than we were yeah and
so as the fear level comes down
what happens now when you recall nancy
pelosi walking into
a salon to get her hair done when she
had specifically told people
that you're not allowed to do that you
feel differently now because you're not
as afraid as you were so there's a long
tail i think on hypocrisy and it's still
spooling out i have to speak i bet this
is going to be like people that are
starting to it's dawning on them now
like now they're calming down they're
gonna see this and it's gonna be like
reliving trauma for these people so when
we or when anyone is gonna approach them
about like hey just so you know i'm not
don't rub their nose in it when people
start coming around
treat it like past trauma be kind and
understanding people went through a lot
the last couple years yeah i know a lot
of people want to say i told you so well
that's not always the best kind of
approach especially when it comes to
someone coming out of a trauma-based
fear state that was instituted by a lot
of very powerful forces the corporate
media the politicians all took this
situation and let's be honest here from
my perspective exploited it to the
fullest extension
extent that they could in a way that
that ratcheted up the numbers of cases
ratcheted up the number of debts that
are now even in question by the
government's own answers and
explanations to what actually was going
on here cnn was talking about
gangbusters for ratings as they were
obsessing about the death counter on
their corporate media broadcast that of
course was celebrating that they were
able to ratchet up those numbers and get
more viewership because of that and that
is a sick mentality that deserves to be
checked and though
they need to be held responsible for it
you know that meme keep calm and axe or
whatever carry on keep calm and carry on
yeah
so uh
i i feel like this the corporate press
and many politicians like aoc were the
ones doing the opposite they were
telling you not to keep calm they were
saying the end is not panic panic yeah
they still are there was just an article
i read
maybe two weeks ago
written by a doctor over at johns
hopkins i forget her name it's not
important though you can look it up it's
very specific though she's laying out
the hellscape
of january and february and i've never
read anything this dire all right all
the hospitals will be full
all of the pharmacies will be closed all
of the shelves will be empty please
listen to me please listen to this is a
doctor at hopkins right now we're
january 10th today in real time and
people are looking around and so what do
we do you know
you're talking about being graceful and
i think that's great and you're talking
about we should understand and i i think
that's great too but look there are
consequences of living at def con five
where's the def con one what's the bad
one one's the better one you can't live
at one
right maybe for 15 days maybe for a
while but but it starts to wear down you
know and it's i mean you don't have to
look too far back into history to see
what happens when people get bored with
being terrified it happens and it's got
nothing to do with numbers or statistics
it's got nothing to do with facts or
data it has to do with with who with the
way we're wired remember in the battle
of britain right during the blitz those
those people were bombed every day and
they went underground and they lived
underground for
for a week and then they started to
stick their heads out bombs still
falling yep you know two weeks later
they're opening shops three weeks later
they're back in school bombs are still
falling the bombs never stop falling but
after a month and a half it was just
look this is bad this is very very very
very bad but we're not going to spend
the rest of our lives in that state
there's videos out of syria during the
civil war in places like aleppo where
the buildings are completely wiped out
there's there's no sign of civilization
but people except for the people that
are carrying food and working and you're
wondering you can hear gunshots go off
in the distance but these people say
it's either i just wither and die in a
hole or i get out to get food and living
even amidst this conflict i think they
needed the panic and they wouldn't be
able to exploit this entire situation if
there wasn't a panic and it's important
to understand they they created it in
many important circumstances with that
fear comes anxiety comes depression
comes a lot of psychological disorders
if we look at the mental health of
america it has steadily declined over
the years and dramatically when when
covet came to the world because
politicians were exploiting that and
this kind of sick deprived behavior i
think is perfectly represented by this
latest la times column that literally is
titled mocking anti-vaxxers deaths is
ghoulish yes but necessary
that is
crazy imagine working on a newspaper
saying this out loud and still
exploiting it when again the data should
be questioned here and the facts still
aren't figured out here so the arguments
she's making here for it being necessary
it's it's such a complex web of of just
emotions that they throw at you so you
don't look at this calmly rationally
because if you did you wouldn't be going
along with any of this nonsense think
about the fact that that article got
past an editor probably several editors
and so the thing that scares me is that
there's somebody in the newsroom who
says
you know they enjoy mocking or they sh
people should be mocking those who die
and then everyone around them being like
yeah we we agree with this and so much
that we want to publish this
that says to me that we're we're really
separated in this country from
celebrating death it's even even being
neutral about it because they may not
agree but they may they're obviously not
disagreeing because they put it forward
and being neutral towards evil is just
as bad as being evil well there you go
right good germans
yeah that's it yeah order followers it
wasn't the nazi party it was
all the ones who sat by but look beside
that it's just uh
i forgot what i was going to say doggone
it was going to be good too
it was going to be a good one it was
going to be a good one it was good oh
as a journalist right i mean somewhere
along the line with an article like the
one you just quoted and with the thing i
was just talking about before
shouldn't somebody be asking the
question
what is persuasive
is it persuasive for instance to point
to the people who for whatever reason
haven't been vaccinated
and identify them
as the proximate cause of all of the
problems now it you can have the
conversation about whether they are or
whether they're not but from an advocacy
standpoint from a journalistic
standpoint you know do those people
find it persuasive to be put into a
box of deplorables we we've had a couple
people on the show we've disagreed with
and typically i'll ask them you know why
don't you you know flies with honey why
don't you try and advocate and be nice
and empathize
it doesn't seem like people want to do
it right so this article saying we
should mock those who die from covet
obviously it's not persuasive obviously
it's antagonistic but they're doing it
not because they actually want to be
persuasive at least in my view they're
doing because i think it is a tribal
rallying cry that will generate traffic
among their side make them feel good you
know you're right we you know you've got
someone who's a really nasty person on
facebook they see the article and they
go that's right i should be a jerk on
facebook but it doesn't feel good but
this is another aspect of it these are
talking points that are issued not just
by l.a times
reporters quote end quote but these are
also similar comments expressed by world
leaders like justin trudeau that when
talking about the unvaccinated said do
we tolerate these people we have uh
rachel the former banker emmanuel macron
who literally came on the world stage
and said these people are not these
people shouldn't be considered citizens
for for what they're doing because
they're irresponsible for their health
these are arguments and talking points
that have ratcheted up at this level
that are extremely insane extremely
draconian from very powerful
institutions very powerful people that
in in my understanding are very
dangerous especially when you look at
them with these specific comments with a
context in history thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time